Thank you all for coming.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for the opportunity
to come speak here. Uh,
today I'm going to be speaking with
you about my book privacy's blueprints,
the battle to control the
design of new technologies.
And I really wants to,
uh,
start off with a series of stories to
tell you a little bit about what the book
is about. So many of
you, if not most of you,
are familiar with the Cambridge
Analytica, Facebook, um,
dust up as it were. Uh, and
there's a, it was a lot going on.
There were lots of information
that was taken from Facebook, uh,
that eventually made its way towards
Cambridge analytic and an outward.
And it caused a huge,
um,
public discussion about
privacy and platforms.
And there was a lot going
on built in with that.
But one of the most
interesting things was, uh,
the fact that there was a big debate about
whether this was originally what they
referred to as a breach or something else.
Ryan.
And one of the things that sort of
came up and one of the things that,
that indeed the platform actually said
is that that permission was actually
granted, um, uh,
through the privacy settings to have
this sort of information given to third
party apps. And in fact
it wasn't just, um,
the one app that was
collecting lots of information.
This was actually a relatively common
practice that people were agreeing to.
But if you actually start to
dig in and think about, well,
what was actually agreed to and when did
it look like you realized it was sort
of one small little option nested within
lots of other small little options that
existed. And while you may technically
have agreed to it, um, it's,
it was sort of binary and
relatively hidden. Um,
and so it resulted in a lot of confusion
because the people that seem to be
angry about it said, well, wait a
second. I didn't even agree to that.
And then of course they were shown exactly
where they did and they said, okay,
well maybe that wasn't the best thing.
The second story I want to talk about.
This is a still taken from an
internet connected baby monitor.
And the most disturbing thing about this,
and this was disturbing in and of itself,
isn't that that there was this one still,
but rather there's an entire search
engine dedicated to finding these sorts of
stills because these sorts of
devices are so routinely compromised.
Um, and, and so easy to, to
sort of take control of that.
There's actually an entire
collection of them online. Um,
which I thought was also
relatively disturbing.
And then the third story that I wanted
to talk about was what many of you may
have been familiar with,
which is the dispute between the Federal
Bureau of Investigation and apple over
whether to build in some sort of
bypass to its encryption scheme and an
authentication protocol to allow
it to access the phone, um,
of the San Bernardino shooter.
Now what are these three
things have in common?
They all are stories about the
design of information technologies.
And in the book I focus on how things are
built and the way in which they affect
our privacy.
And I want to make three points today and
I make try to make three larger points
in the book. One design matters
for privacy and more than that,
which may seem relatively evident,
we need to have a better conversation
to explore why design matters and how
design matters for our privacy because
I think it matters more than what most
people regularly consider too.
And this is the main thesis of the book,
which is why it's in bold,
which is the privacy laws should take
design more seriously and not just the law
but also uh, industry policy,
industry standards, industry norms.
We focus a lot on personal data,
which data, what data is being
collected, how is it being used,
who is it being sharing shared with.
We focused a lot about transparency,
but I argue that there's actually, there's
a, there's a gap, there's a, there's a,
a huge area within which design affects
a lot of what people to be considered,
their personal privacy interest that we
don't regularly talk about in law and in
industry policy and three,
and this is perhaps one of the more
controversial aspects of the book.
A design agenda for law and policy should
have roots and consumer protection and
surveillance law,
not the standard data protection
framework that isn't becoming incredibly
popular through frameworks like the Gdpr,
which everyone has
probably at least Molly,
where I've given the thousands of emails
that you received somewhere around late
April that says we've updated our terms.
Um,
and it's built around this model that
tends to prioritize certain kinds of data
collection and processing rules.
I think at the expense of ignoring some
nuances about the ways in which design
actually controls our privacy.
Okay,
so let me expand upon these three
points. One, design matters for privacy.
What do I mean by that?
I mean the design matters for privacy
because it is everywhere because it is
power and because it is political.
First design is everywhere.
Many people might recognize what this is.
Does anyone know what this is?
Has anyone seen this before?
It is a promo user interface,
early user interface for
the APP. Snapchat. Now,
if you were to look at this knowing
nothing, sometimes I give this talk and I,
I speak with people that haven't used
technology that much or only sort of
casual users have a lot of apps and
so they've never seen this at all.
And so I like to sort of pause and I say,
if you had never seen this before,
what would you,
this user interface is,
it is designed to accomplish and
some of the usual answers I get are,
well it's probably something that relates
to taking and sending of a picture,
right? We can tell that exists
for, we saw the timer here.
Where does the time or probably do
if we had to guess. Yeah, it, it,
it makes the, the picture of disappear
after maybe a certain amount of time.
We see the scroll wheel that we can
select, right? So we clearly have options,
right? It's clearly meant not just
for taking photos and storing them,
but for sharing them.
We can tell because we look at,
we see a sin button, right? It's got
the little arrow. And then one of,
one of my favorite things about
this user interface and one of the,
one of the most demonstrative sort of
signals that we see about the way in which
this is supposed to be used.
What do you think this particular app,
just looking at this,
what kinds of pictures do you think
the APP is inviting you to send?
Naughty pictures, right? It originally,
this is how snapchat was sort of
perceived publicly, right? Uh,
and you can't blame them because look,
we've got an incredibly carefully cropped
a little square here where we can't
tell whether these young women are
clothed or not. They're having fun.
And the implicit message built in through
every aspect of design of this user
interface is that you can trust this app
with things that you might not trust in
more permanent sorts of social
media, right? Because it goes away.
It is safer than if you were to use,
say,
a some other service that, that where
the pictures are stored forever.
And all of this is conveyed
with less than three words.
It's all signals.
It's all things that we intuitively
seem to understand through the design of
information technologies. And I started
looking for examples for this book.
And once you start to look for examples
of the ways in which design affects your
privacy, you see them all over the place
and, and not just in in obvious ways,
but in subtle ways.
So I don't have to tell everybody
here with this technology is,
and there were some design decisions that,
um,
that went into Google glass and I
thought were incredibly interesting.
The most obvious privacy relevant
feature for Google glass is what
the camera on the front,
right? The one that's,
it's literally staring straight at us.
Um,
but that's not the design feature.
I mean,
I guess you could have designed
glass without the camera.
That was a design decision
that implicated, um,
people's privacy because it's able
to be surveilled. But of course,
the counter argument to that is this
camera doesn't really do a lot that isn't
already being done by another camera.
Right.
The one that everyone has in their phones.
And so the design decision that's
relevant for Google glass is not just that
there's a camera,
but the camera is always
potentially visible.
Right now there's a small transaction
cost, but it's significant at scale,
which is in order to take a
picture with our normal phones,
we have to reach into our phone,
pull it out, right, open it up,
we fit a little bit with it, we
aim it, and then we take the photo.
Now that doesn't seem like
a lot on a per time basis,
but that small transaction cost actually
I think has a tendency to make people
feel more comfortable with the fact that
everyone is carrying around a sort of
pres, a persistent a
surveillance device in their,
in their pockets all the time. Whereas
glass was net with a much more resistance,
right?
People tended to be more uncomfortable
with it than they did with their phones.
And think the reason why is because
the camera was always there, right?
The transaction costs of having to dig
into your pocket was suddenly gone and I
had to do, was utter a command or um, uh,
sort of readily activated.
There was another design decision that
I thought was really relevant to Google
glass.
They didn't get a lot of attention,
but it's my understanding mid glass
did not provide support for facial
recognition technologies,
which was an interesting design decision.
Um,
and one that I think also
had privacy implications,
positive privacy implications.
I don't have to tell anyone here
with this symbol is as well, right?
But for those that aren't familiar,
this is the symbol of incognito mode.
When you open up Google chrome browser
and you go into incognito mode,
you see, or at one point I believe
that the icon is now changed.
But at one point you saw this icon
and I always like to ask people,
this is a, this is a design, right?
It's a, it's a, it's a signal to people.
And if you were to just see this,
what would you think the signal was?
What is this meant to convey?
I'm sorry.
Concealment, right, which is
of course it's the purpose.
I mean it's called incognito
mode and we've got our,
it seems like a sort of classic 1940s gum.
She right.
Someone that doesn't want to be seen, they
put the, they can put their collar up,
they've got a hat that they can
pull down low, maybe glasses.
Again,
the,
the implicit message just from looking
at this is that you're safer if you want
to hide. Now, of course, that's
not exactly how incognito
mode works, right? And,
and indeed, when you open
up incognito mode, um,
you've got a list of things they say,
by the way,
here are all the people that can still
see you when using incognito mode,
which is a very important disclosure.
But absent that, you might think, oh,
well I'm using the same
browser, right? The browser,
that doesn't record any history of me at
all. Right? It's completely incognito.
And so without that,
I think important disclosure,
this design would tend to
shape people's expectations.
And so when you look around,
you tend to see the sort of
design decisions everywhere
that tend to be relevant
for people's decisions about what
to disclose, how much to disclose,
and how safe they are in disclosing.
Now,
the second point that I want to make
about design, if the design is power,
one of my favorites experiments that I
talk a little bit about in the book was
done by Leslie John.
I'm Alessandro queasy and George
Loewenstein at Carnegie Mellon University.
And they got several people in to answer
this series of questions in a survey in
a on a screen.
And they sat down and they were presented
with a screen like this and they asked
him a number of different questions
and this is just a snapshot.
And the questions ranged from sort of
banal to relatively intimate to incredibly
intimate. And this is just a short
little snapshot here. They said,
have you ever smoked marijuana?
Have you ever cheated
while in a relationship?
Have you ever driven when you were
pretty sure you were over the legal blood
alcohol level asking you to
admit to committing a crime? Now,
what's the first thing that you
notice when I put this screen up?
How bad are you?
Right?
And so there were a series of design
decisions that I think were particularly
relevant here.
One is the fact that bad is
sort of capitalized, right?
And then they use the sort of cutesy,
you sort of tech speak, right?
How bad are you?
Multiple question marks,
which is indicative of what youth,
right exuberance.
What else do we have
relevant to design here?
The logo, right? I said devil,
but it's not a bad devil.
It's like an Emoji devil.
Like acute devil, right?
There's one other design decision
that I thought was really interesting.
The font,
it is written in Comic Sans and no one
in the history of the world is taking
anything seriously written
in Comic Sans Font, right?
And the overall implication, of course,
of all of these design decisions,
despite asking incredibly
intimate questions,
questions that can implicate
you in a crime, is that you're,
how bad are you? You're
bad. You know, you're bad.
Everyone was just a little bit bad,
right?
That's sort of the implication of every
single design feature built into this.
And then of course the control group,
they had looked like this.
Gone is the sand Saraf is,
is the Comic Sans Font replaced with
this, you know, very formal sand Saraf.
You know,
funds gone is our cute little question
about how bad are you and now it's just
replaced with the imprimatur
of Carnegie Mellon University,
a very prestigious university.
Right.
But the question's remains
exactly the same. Right?
And,
and I want to read directly because I
don't want to miss quotes the results of
their study.
Um,
but they call this the frivolous
looking interface in this,
the non frivolous looking interface.
And uh,
they found that relative to the non
frivolous interface participants in the
frivolous looking survey that
asked identical questions,
we're on average 1.7 times more likely
to admit having engaged in risky
behaviors.
For example,
a participant in the frivolous looking
survey was on average 2.03 times more
likely to admit having ever taken
nude pictures of himself or a partner.
And the authors conclude people,
it seems,
feel more comfortable providing personal
information on unprofessional sites
that are arguably, uh,
particularly likely to misuse it.
Design is power design doesn't
necessarily dictate behavior,
but it channels its every single design
decision makes a certain reality more or
less likely, right? And so it,
it provides an incredible amount of power.
And that leads me to my third point,
which is that design is political
design is always political.
And when I say political, I don't mean
political in terms of Capitol Hill.
I mean political in terms of
the distribution of power.
So I give this talk a little
and sometimes in response,
people will come up
afterwards and they'll say,
why are you targeting design as something
that we should be focused about in
law? Right? Instead of targeting
the tools that we use to create, to,
to create problems, why don't we
target the harmful problems themselves?
One of the examples that's been put
forth recently is a knife can be used for
good or bad, but we don't
ban knives, Ryan and said,
we say you can't use a knife to stab
someone, but you can use it to cut food.
And so, um, and so it's always some
sort of version of the argument that,
that there are no bad is only
bad uses of those technologies.
And that should be the focus
of our policy and law efforts.
But I think that that
actually, um, tends to, uh,
cut against the fact that I don't think
that there's such a thing as a neutral
technology given the fact that every
single design decision is meant to affect
the world, right? That's what design is.
It's a series of decisions that we get
reflected in some sort of substance that
affects the world and
in some particular way,
then there's no such thing
as neutral technologies.
Even ignoring certain realities is an
acceptance of those realities in a certain
sense.
Um,
and so we cannot ignore
technology in the role of design,
in law and policy. We have to
confront it head on. Um, and there,
there may be reasons why we explicitly
decided not to have rules against
legislating technology. We don't
want regulators, for example,
dictating from top to bottom, every single
design decision in a ham fisted way,
right? Because, you know, it's,
it's difficult to think that they
would know better how to build a lot of
particulars in technologies
and people that live it. Um,
but that too has its own costs.
Right?
And we need to be specific about
which costs we want to embrace, right?
And how to better balance them with the
full range of concerns that we have.
And the only way that we're going to
do that is if we explicitly embrace the
design of technology and how that is
powerful in our laws and policies.
So that leaves me to my next point,
which is that privacy law should take
design more seriously because right now it
doesn't, it may seem like it relatively
does and there may be some, uh,
in this room are listening in online
that have had experience dealing with
regulators and the,
with the European Union and the general
data protection regulation that deal
with privacy by design and
privacy by default. Um,
but actually I will argue that largely
privacy law and privacy policy and the
rules that we have even internally about
privacy have a major design gap turns
out.
So I teach privacy law at northeastern
university and it's a whole semester long
course,
but it turns out there are basically
only three privacy rules that you have to
follow. Um, and so I can
save you all a lot of money.
If you're interested in
taking a private slot course.
I'm just gonna summarize it now.
One of the rules is follow the
fair information practices.
This is the underlying ethos of the
entire general data protection regulation.
It's the, it's the idea behind, uh,
statutes that you are
probably very familiar with,
like the fair credit reporting
acts. Um, oh, even HIPAA has a,
a sense of,
uh,
follow the fair information practices
and the fair information practices are
things that are so fundamental to our
understanding of fairness with data
processing that you probably have already
internalized them without thinking
about them.
For example,
people should have control over
their information. They should, uh,
databases should be transparent
about what they're collecting.
They should give people notice about what
they're collecting and the ability to
delete information or correct information
that you should only collect what you
need and that you should delete it
when you're done with it. Right?
The data minimization principle,
there's the principle of accountability
that we should be accountable for these
rules. There's the
principal, um, that, uh,
people should have certain sort of access
rights for portability rights to their
data.
These are all things that we've been
talking about for a long time and they all
started with the fair
information practices,
which are actually originated in the mid
and late 1970s and then made their way
through and now are as close as the
world has come to a common language of
privacy,
which is pretty remarkable
when you consider all the
varying different cultural
connotations that play into
conceptions of privacy.
The fact that we have a basic set of
rules on how to fairly collect and process
data is remarkable and
the fips are important.
They're necessary.
But here's the problem with the Phipps,
they look like this,
right?
This is the way in which
they get reflected because
if you look at the Phipps
and almost always boils down
to this idea of control,
if you ask the CEOs of every major tech
company in the United States in the
world, how do you respect
the privacy of your users?
I bet money that they were almost all
respond with some version of we put people
in control of their own information.
This is one of the most
dominant conceptualizations
of privacy in the United
States and around the world.
The idea being that if we give users
control of their information and they get
to decide for themselves what they want
to do with their information and what
they're okay with,
they do a risk calculation and
if they are given that control,
then if they exercise it,
then presumably the giving of that control
is enough to justify certain sorts of
data practices cause people approve
it, right? They have control over it.
Data Subjects,
autonomy in theory is respected.
The, the uh, platform.
Collecting information has done its moral
duty under this conceptualization and
my offering, the control and
we can all proceed together.
And here's the problem with that.
And here's a problem with control.
Think of thinking privacy in
terms of control generally,
which is really popular,
not just an industry. Governments
conceptualize privacy is control.
Advocates conceptualize privacy's control.
It is by far probably the most
popular way to define privacy.
I teach privacy law and on the first day
I asked my students to write out what
privacy is and say,
what is privacy?
And then we go around the room and I
have 20 to 30 students and I usually get
around five to 10 different answers,
but almost always the most popular
response is control over personal
information.
But again,
the way that control is reflected
in practice is through design.
It is through buttons,
right? Toggle switches,
which in theory is still fine.
Everyone knows what this is.
Green means yes.
Gray means no and it's a toggle switch.
Can Google maps collect your
Geo location information?
Green means yes. Gray means no.
Yes, I have exercised control.
I have made a decision. Privacy
is respected. Onward. We go,
except of course it doesn't always work
out like that because it never looks
just like that does it.
Right?
We have a series of decisions to make
because we don't want the decision to be
just binary.
If it's too binary,
it's two abstracted and I
privacy is complicated. There
are nuances, right? Yes.
No doesn't give enough choices. So
we say, okay, I need lots of choices.
I want nuance, right? This is,
this is the inherent tension in defining
privacy is control is give me nuance.
So tech companies respond and they say,
okay,
we'll give you lots of different choices,
right?
Rather than just sort of one off by an
area, we'll give you lots of choices.
Except of course that means that users
are now responsible for analyzing those
choices. And you say, okay, I've got,
I've got that for the find my iPad
button and in location based alerts,
I guess that's good. Location based
I ads, I don't know what that means.
Share my location green. Okay. I guess
I guess I'll try to figure that one out.
Wifi network. I don't know. I don't know
what that but does, but I guess it's okay.
Um, diagnostics and usage. Peep
popular near me. I guess. That's good.
And we have to make all of these sorts
of implicit risk calculations over and
over again, which is costly in
terms of personal resources, right?
Because people have limited amounts
of time. So we go through, but okay.
So let's say we look at this,
we make our design is set up in this
way for us to to effectuate the control
that we're given. We do it and
we say, Ooh, okay, I think I'm,
I think I'm good. I think I've set my
settings the way I want them. And then we,
we take a deep breath and we
back up and we say, Oh dear,
I've got lots of buttons to
press over and over. Right?
And when the settings change,
I've got to update them again.
The problem with thinking about privacy
in terms of control is that people are
gifted with so much control that they
choke on it and it becomes in practice
away for a risk of loss
to be shifted onto users.
Because if you fail to
exercise that control,
it's not the problem of the company.
They gave you the control, right?
They're giving you the options,
that's what you wanted. And so it's,
there's an inherent tension but
almost as never going to be resolved,
which is if you abstracted
away and make control easy,
if you provide one button
for all of our our issues,
then it becomes too generalized right
there too. Too much stuff washed in.
And so our ability to do a,
a meaningful risk calculus is washed away.
But if you provide every option under
the sun, then it becomes overburdensome,
right? It's a, it's a d dos
attack on our brain and there's,
there's no way that we can respond.
It's scale.
And so control I think is actually one of,
uh,
fundamentally one of the
misguided actually ways to
think about privacy in the
modern data ecosystem because it's never
going to, it just doesn't scale. Right?
And left we started having a conversation
about prioritize your control,
which gets really interesting,
which we can talk about later.
So there's this massive design
gap in follow the Phipps,
this ethic that we follow in all privacy
law and and all and industry sort of
rules,
which is you should give people control
because design is a leveraged to instead
of being autonomy enhancing and actually
it's autonomy, corrosive, right?
Because we're given all of these choices
were sort of burdening them or it's
abstracted away to the point where it's
meaningless. All right? That's rule one.
Rule Two is do not lie
relatively simple rule, right?
The Federal Trade Commission,
which is the nation's top a regulator
of privacy has a authority to regulate
unfair and deceptive trade practices
and as part of its regulation,
it has one major rule is just
don't lie to people, right?
That sounds relatively easy. The problem
with the do not lie ethos of course,
is one of the similar problems to
transparency and control generally,
which is you can put technical truths
in a place that nobody's going to read
them and we all know where you put the
things where you nobody to read it.
All right,
where do we put it?
If I want to be sure to put something
in a place where I know no users ever
going to see it,
where am I going to stick it?
The privacy policy or the terms of
use, right. I do this for a living.
I am a a a privacy law professor and I
cannot scroll through the terms of use
quick enough to get to, I agree, right?
Because of course there's no way that it
that at scale anyone could collectively
read them.
Right?
It'd be we'd have to take two days off
of vacation a year just to read all the
privacy policies we come
into and so do not lie.
Can also get circumvented through design,
through putting it in a place where
technical truth is is ignored,
and then there's the do not harm ethic.
That's the last one.
So the Federal Trade
Commission also says don't do,
don't engage in unfair trade practices.
That's harm users in a way that's a not
avoidable by the users themselves and in
a way that's not out balanced by
countervailing benefits to the consumer.
That's the sort of tests they use. But
of course, the do not harm ethic is also,
uh, easily subverted through
design because in the modern age,
the threshold for harm to rise to a
legal violation is sort of high, right?
Um, they, if, if you're going to
bring a lawsuit against the company,
then you don't want the harm
to be a, this is creepy, right?
Which is some of the things that
happen, right? And creepy. It's not a,
it's not a real word that has boundaries
around, right. What is creepy?
Lots of things could possibly creepy.
Um, but that varies wildly according,
you know,
across the spectrum.
And so the law and in many
ways rightly actually says,
you've got to have a
real tangible harm here.
You've got to have some sort of financial
harm, right? If someone, your identity,
someone stole your money, or you have to
have some sort of clear emotional harm,
right? And often it is your naked body
was exposed publicly, right? Or something,
something very visceral and something
that, that has a clear boundary to it.
But of course,
many of the sorts of things that people
quantify as privacy harms in the modern
age is not actually those
sorts of visceral harms,
which can be relatively rare,
but rather it's a little bit more of
a death by a thousand cuts, right?
We reveal a little bit of information
here and we trickle a little bit of
information there,
none of it,
which rises to the level of what we
would consider to be a privacy harm.
But collectively we look up one day
and we all become vulnerable, right?
And we all see that that's,
we've gone down this road without actually
having any one particular violation.
Yeah. And here we are with lots of our
information sort of expose that can,
that could ultimately
be leveraged against us.
And so design also sort of does that
through sort of the way in which we
encourage short little
amounts of information to be
disclosed here. And they, oh,
it's just a little information here.
It's just a little information there.
But collectively it becomes a big issue.
All right,
so at this point you may be saying,
all right, smart Guy Wolf. This,
we've got the problems,
what are we going to do about it?
And that actually is the
next part of the book,
which is why I proposed
a theory of privacy,
law and design and the theory
is actually built around values,
boundaries and tools and the values that
I advocate for or actually not control.
Even though that's the dominant framework,
I think there are better
values that we can embrace.
Not only that will give us industry
in US law a much clearer identity with
respect to protecting personal information
but also one that doesn't sort of
inherently have this tension where you
have to choose between a meaningless
abstraction or overwhelming nuance and
that's trusted security and autonomy.
In other words,
I argue that our law and policy should
encourage design that is trustworthy that
promotes or at least values
obscurity and enhance his autonomy.
Now what do I mean by that?
Trust I think is one of the most
important values, uh, in the modern age.
With respect to the disclosure of
personal information in platforms,
trust is key for commerce.
Trust is key for personal
relationships and intimacy.
Trust is key for self exploration.
We tend not to disclose
to other people in a,
in an attempt to sort of figuring
out who we are unless we trust those,
if everything we say can be used against
us and we tend not to sort of engage in
self exploration.
And so our design should reflect that
our design should reflect a sense of
discretion, not necessarily
confidentiality, but just discretion.
We don't disclose everything all the time,
right? This can be de identification,
this is gonna be disclosure
within a limited community. Um,
it should encourage a sense of protection.
Now this is a little more obvious,
right?
Which is a don't store people's passwords
in clear text and salt and Hash and
uh, let's encrypt traffic.
We should protect the data.
This is what we would refer to.
Maybe it's data security,
a sense of honesty and honesty
is different from transparency.
Transparency often gets touted as, look
at we, we've opened up the books to you,
right? We, you can look inside and
you can see whatever is available.
But that's actually different than what
I would consider to be acting honestly,
honestly is affirmatively disclosing
the things that users want to know that
maybe you would prefer not to tell them
that they should probably know. Right?
In other words, it's, it's a little
bit more of affirmative obligation, um,
as a warning rather than
full transparency. And then
finally, and this is the,
this is the hard one with
respect to trust. Um,
design should be loyal to the user.
And what I mean by that is it shouldn't
elevate the interests of the platform
unreasonably in or an unreasonable ways
over the interest of the data subject.
And we can talk about what I mean
by that. Uh, Eh, in a minute. And,
and that would be trustworthy design
design that is discrete, protective,
honest and loyal.
Now another sort of a
design choice which doesn't,
isn't quite as established in law and
policy is the value of obscurity obscurity
is the idea that when information is hard
are unlikely to be found or understood
than it is to a relative degree.
Safe.
We rely upon zones of obscurity
all the time in our everyday lives.
And we don't even realize it.
How many people here have eaten out at
a restaurant within the last two weeks?
A number of people.
Do any of you remember who was
sitting two tables away from you?
Probably not. You were in
public. Everyone can see you.
But of course we've delong
since deleted that information.
I flew here yesterday on an airplane.
I don't remember what the person
sitting next to me looked like, right?
Even though it was in public.
And we do this to help sort of ease to
prevent cognitive overburdening and we
rely upon this risk calculus all
the time to make decisions. Um,
when I'm walking out in public,
um, you know, if, if you know,
you quickly want to sort of scratch in a,
in a delicate place and you look around,
no one's looking right, you do it right.
Even though maybe if that were
posted on the walls, the, uh,
the Times Square Jumbo Tron, then you
would have second thoughts about it.
But the odds of that are incredibly small.
When you go shopping in a
grocery store or a drugstore,
um, you're in public, you're picking
out things that are delicate,
but the odds that someone is standing
right behind you writing down every single
thing that you purchase is incredibly low.
Right?
And the odds of that ever coming back
to hurt, she was also incredibly low.
So we value obscurity and the
harm comes when our obscurity is,
is taken away from us in dramatic ways.
In other words, they're lurches obscurity.
Lurches um,
I've been,
I've written a very clear critically
about facial recognition technologies and
one of the reasons why as I view
it as an incredible obscurity,
lurch our faces while public,
um,
basically allow us still to be relatively
private as we walk into a crowd.
But facial recognition technology is
threatened. That ability, uh, it, it,
it represents a dramatic
obscurity, lurch and online. Uh,
some of my research is focused on,
there are things that can obscure you
or make you more obvious like search
visibility, unprotected access, right?
Whether we protect something
with a password, um,
whether someone uses their
real name or a pseudonym or no,
no identifier at all and
whether things are clear, right?
Sometimes things are obscure because
people like the context to make sense of
them. If I were to tell you all
right now, um, hey, by the way,
I just got the test results back.
It's positive.
You would have no idea what that means,
right?
It's obscurity you and it's safe to me
because you have no idea what that means.
Um,
but if you had the backstory,
which is maybe that my wife
and I were trying to conceive,
then you would say, oh,
I now understand, right? This is sort
of hiding in plain sight with content.
And so there are ways in which we can
obscure information and preserve that
obscurity. And then finally, the
value that I advocate for is autonomy.
Now autonomy is difference than control.
Control can serve autonomy,
right?
The right to be free from
external interference, the
right to self determination,
but, but if too much control
actually threatens that autonomy.
So I argue that a better value to
embrace is autonomy rather than control.
All right.
And so that leads me to the final part
of the book where I argue that a design
agenda should have roots and consumer
protection and surveillance law rather
than saying, well, the fair information
practices, which everybody accepts, uh,
are, uh, the thing that we should,
we should adhere to. If you look,
I said there are actually
other areas of the law,
but if thought this out that
if taken design seriously,
then I proposed sorts of boundaries,
uh, to avoid deceptive design,
abusive design and dangerous
design. Deceptive design, uh,
is something that it,
it, we relatively, uh,
are doing a good job with both,
I think within industry and within
policy in terms of not outright deceiving
people.
You know,
if it says this is a path complaints filed
by the Federal Trade Commission where
add friends actually didn't
just allow you to add France,
but it actually automatically sort of
went in and scooped up the entire contact
list.
A,
and then there's also the idea that
maybe we should avoid abusive design,
which is the leveraging of people's
own limitations against them.
And this happens sometimes
in everyday life.
We tend to sort of leverage people's
own limitations against them.
But it's another thing entirely to build
an entire machine built to leverage
people's own limitations against them.
This is an example of um,
pricing,
different differential pricing based on
people's personal characteristics or the
thing that made my privacy law students
really mad when year, which is, uh,
the fact that a certain travel,
a website could tell whether using
a PC or a Mac and would show the,
um, the cheaper, um, uh,
hotel rooms to the people using windows
pcs and the more expensive hotel rooms
for the people using MACs based on
the assumption that people that had
Macintosh's we're actually
being more, were, had more,
had more money and we're more affluence.
Um, but there are tons of examples.
So one of the examples that pops up is,
is when leveraging people's own
limitations against them is our desire for
conformity, right? People have a
strong desire sort of not to be,
to be with a group or to do what everyone
else does and sometimes that can be
worked against this. So, uh, this shows
up in the literature around dark patterns,
which is a,
a really interesting website.
And this is one where it says get 10% off.
And then at the bottom it says,
no thanks. I'd rather pay full
price for delicious tea, right?
Which is sort of shaming people,
right? But like, oh, okay,
well I don't want to be the sucker here.
And there's several other examples
where you see, because people's, uh,
po voting records tend to be
public in most states. Um,
some people have actually
leveraged that and they said,
all your neighbors voted
and you didn't write.
Here are the people that voted
and you didn't votes. Look,
look how irresponsible you are,
right? Which is sort of a shaming, um,
or a a one here, which is,
um, at the bottom it says,
no thanks, I'm fine with losing customers.
I mean, who wants to click that right?
Now, again, this is a very subtle
sort of manipulative technique,
but it's one that is at scale,
could tend to be a
harmful in the right way.
Another example of using people's
own limitations against them is, uh,
the use of like double and triple
negatives, right? So here it's decline.
Release of directory information. Note,
most parents do not choose this option,
right? So we've got lots of knots here.
I do not want the release information.
So when you start layering like double
and triple negatives, then it's not,
it's not lying, right? It's not,
it's not deceitful, but it's,
it's leveraging people's inability to
sort of process the double and triple
negative. I don't not never want
this information released. Um,
and then finally there's dangerous design.
Some designs are just inherently
dangerous. This is a spy camera.
It's designed for more or less one thing,
right?
Which just to catch people in
various states of undress, right?
Because it's a clothes hanger,
right?
It's meant to be put in rooms where
people are taking clothes on and off.
And I argue that that's
dangerous design is as,
as dangerous as surveillance
that you know about is,
I've used surveillance as you don't know
about it to be even more potentially
dangerous and there are lots of potential
responses to this and I go into this
and the second part of the book,
soft responses,
moderate responses in robust responses,
so a soft response is we don't have to
come in as regulators heavy handed and
say we're regulating this to the hilt.
Sometimes what privacy
needs is some funding,
it needs some innovation, it needs some
opportunity. It needs standardization,
right?
It needs educational opportunities.
So I argue for a lot of different ways
to improve people's privacies without
passing some really
heavy handed regulations.
Sometimes we need to moderate response
is maybe judges just need to be a little
more
sensitive to the role that design plays
in people shaping people's expectations
and their choices and maybe regulators.
Do you see this is an example of the
padlock icon, which is ubiquitous online.
We use it all the time. It's the, it is.
It is the the physical symbol of security,
but we don't really question what
it means to people as much. Right?
When people see the padlock icon,
they usually think they're safe or secure,
that that's what a lock means.
But what does,
what does it really mean on the practice?
And maybe there,
there are ways in which these sort of
Paluch icons might act as as sort of
implicit promises.
And then finally there may be a need
for heavy handed regulations in certain
instances.
One of the things I've argued for is in
support of as the ban on spyware that we
have right now, which is
I think relatively, um,
can be used and really malicious ways.
And then another thing that's a little
more controversial is I've argued in
favor of moratoriums and bans on
facial recognition technology,
which I view as one of the most uniquely
dangerous technology surveillance
technologies ever invented. And
then the final part of the book, I,
I lay out what these,
this blueprint of this design agenda
might look in three different kinds of
context,
social media,
hide and seek technologies
and the Internet of things,
which is basically just a
plea from me to stop for,
to tech companies to stop connecting
people's underwear to the Internet,
which is one of the things.
So, um, and with that,
I would love to go ahead and go
to the question answer period.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
Given some examples of bad designs, uh,
can you give an example of a good design,
particularly in the area of providing
user autonomy as you described?
Oh, okay. Um, that's, uh, uh,
actually there are several,
I think very good
designs. Um, one might be,
there are areas in which, so after
I sort of rail on control, um,
a lot, there are areas in which control
might actually be really useful.
I liked the data subject rights.
I also sort of critique the Gdpr,
but now a backtrack on that.
A little sue data subject rights that
allow you to log in, review profiles.
Um,
uh,
information that's kept a voucher I
think are very useful because they can be
done at the election of the
user. Um, dashboards for example,
that allow you to review histories,
locations. I think those are,
those are very good.
And they,
my general principle is that people should
be protected regardless of what they
choose.
But if there are ways in which they
can exercise autonomy on top of that
baseline level of protection, then
that that should be encouraged. Um,
there are also small little things that
I liked that a lot of people actually
critique is not going far enough,
but I like because they're obscurity
protective. Um, for example, uh,
youtube released a tool that
allowed you to blur people's faces.
I believe. I love that tool. Um,
and one of the reasons I love it is
because it's obscurity protecting, right?
It's one that if you happen to
another person who was in the video,
then maybe you would recognize them.
But to the world,
that's actually a pretty good
design. Right? So in other words,
people are largely protected.
We often don't want to be protected from
everybody just from certain sorts of
risks, right? So, um, uh, people, uh,
having the right to be forgotten,
it's one of these things where
people often want their name.
This is associated with being
found for certain results, right?
They don't need the information gone.
They just don't want the HR person who
is reviewing their application for a job.
They want to find it.
Right?
And so there are certain sorts of things
they can protect obscurity and design
like that. And I think the youtube a
Facebook video is a great example of that.
So how do you consider a metadata
like derived data for by data, right?
How has that kind of plan
to this and other people?
Other people's data of me.
So like there was the Facebook thing.
I think we're right.
Other people had data on me and I won't
be able to see their data of me, right?
So for instance,
if they had a phone number of me,
but I never authorized Facebook
to have my phone number,
they had it Facebook and I,
my phone number.
And I don't know that
Facebook has my phone number.
The question is sort of what is the
role of Metadata and all of this?
And this is what I think
really illustrates the limits
of the control conception
of privacy because so much is
actually out of our control.
A really good example is the genetic
information, right? So, so, um,
my sister, uh, Eh got one of the,
the popular sort of tests and,
and gave away or genetic information and
I was really a little uneasy about it
cause I was like, that's it.
That's my information too.
And I've got no control over that at all.
Um,
which is why I argued that we should
have less reliance on control because
control ultimately sort of becomes
unraveled at this stage, right?
It's inability to control it. This is
where argued for the importance of trust.
Um, this is where relationships
of trust matter, um,
now it's, there are
costs to that. So if we,
if we think of privacy in terms of trust,
then inherently we've just made
this conceptualization relational,
right? So, um, so then, uh,
there are advantages to that in that now
I can ask you if you have metadata on
me,
right?
Or for platform has metadata on multiple
people to act in a certain way. A loyal,
for example, to not leverage that
information against me. Um, I'm,
I don't think that just because
information is disclosed,
your privacy isn't necessarily gone.
I think that we disclosed
relationships within information,
within relationships
with trust all the time.
But what it does mean is that sometimes
there are our parties that have no
relationship,
that have that information,
that can then violate your privacy.
So date of brokers who would be
an obvious example where, um,
they don't have a direct relationship
with the data subjects, uh, in ways that,
that platforms that collect
information directly do, but,
but they get information
from various streams. Um,
and so my general sense is that we should
have a baseline set of rules that even
apply to data brokers,
but that a lot of our issues with respect
to and metadata and a lot of these
sort of unraveling problems can be solved
through thinking of privacy in terms
of trust.
So the just the fact that you have it
right or that someone else has it isn't
the end of the story.
Rather there are now things that you
shouldn't be able to do with that
information.
We have a question from
the dory from cane.
I found that I quickly
learned to click on those.
I'm fine with losing customers buttons
because the popup is blocking the task.
I was trying to complete.
What are some tips for making sure people
know how to go back and change their
mind when it's no longer time critical?
Again, I mean not to make everything in
illustration of the limits of the control
conceptualization of privacy. But
um, often when we think of consent,
consent is, is implemented in sort of
binary terms. Like I agreed to this.
And then once that has gotten,
then it sort of in perpetuity exist and
you don't have to re ask for it again,
even though people often change their
minds or circumstances change. Um,
this is where I do think that there is
some responsibility on the part of users
to take advantage of the
tools that are given to them,
if those tools are given to
them in an easy to use way. Um,
I encourage everyone to at least
take a few minutes as part of your,
maybe not daily but maybe weekly or
monthly routine to do a little digital
hygiene. Um, you know,
search your own name on various search
engines to see what's coming up. Um,
look at the, if you have accounts, um,
and sometimes you have accounts even
for only defensive purposes, right?
So I sometimes people I get
resistant to it, I say, well,
I don't want to sign up
for an account for x, y,
z because then they'll have
even more information out of me,
which I'm sympathetic to. But, um,
if it allows you to then sort of log
in and regularly delete information or
cleanse information, then that might
be a positive. And then, um, uh,
take advantage of, of I
think popular ad-ons. Um,
I use ad blockers, uh, which I know is
controversial, but I think that's, um,
that that's another possible tool.
And then finally,
and this is just the thing that I
throw out in generally is if two factor
authentication has ever offered
anywhere, use it, um, and, and,
uh, use it, uh, sort
of early and often is,
is my example. But, but I do think
that that vanity searches, you know,
learning how to, to work within
dashboards, um, is at least a key part.
It can't be everything. Right. My, my,
my argument is that often users are
being asked to do too much, but,
but there is some sort of expectation
that I think we can have a views.
There's two at least, sort
of try to, to exercise some,
some diligence with the tool set given
what are your thoughts on premium options?
Um,
so we're starting to see a lot
of companies moving towards that.
I know we have a youtube
premium option, etc. Um, as a,
as a method for coming back to
your concept of control, right.
Do you see that as valid?
I'm of two minds for the premium
options. I mean on one hand, um,
I liked the premium options because the
business model seems a little clearer,
right? So one of the things that I've
always been drawn to is when you can,
when you win,
everybody's incentives are sort of out
in the open and we know sort of what
we're dealing with it, it becomes a
lot easier and easier to trust. Um,
I think for the premium models to work,
um,
there has to be not just, um,
some sort of soft promises, but I,
but I think really robust promises.
I would love the idea of,
of platforms being able to opt in to
sort of the gold standard of privacy,
which is the, the true level of
trustworthiness where, where they, they,
they say we will be loyal,
we will be discreet,
we will be honest to the sort of
highest standard. Um, and then,
and then that can drive people
to sign up for companies. Right?
It can be a competitive advantage.
And I've,
I've always longed for privacy
to be a competitive advantage.
And I think that we're seeing a
little traction on that model. But,
but then the other side of me worries a
little about premium models because the
other thing that I worry about is that,
um,
privacy becomes something only that
people that have affordances can have a,
and I really worry about the sort
of, uh, equities where we say,
if you pay that,
if you pay the the gold standard option,
you get privacy for everyone that can't
afford it. They know, they, you know,
they don't have that. Um, and
so, so for that, for that reason,
I'm, I'm still actually struggling
with, with a lot of the way that,
that cashes out in, in, in
terms of policy, um, because it,
I do worry about that.
And we have one more question on the
dory from Keith. Uh, what are we,
what are we all missing about dragon fly?
Um,
and the context is a wired story
of Sundar at the wired summit.
So,
so
dragon fly,
as I understand it,
is the initiative for Google to be,
to go in to, to enter China's market.
Right. And I understand, I mean,
if I'm understanding the stories correctly
and I haven't read a lot about it,
so I actually can't provide a,
I think a nuanced discussion,
but I have thought a lot about the
values that get reflected in technology.
And so to that extent,
I think it's worth having an
explicit conversation about,
um,
what,
what the affordances of
dragon fly would be. Um,
if it facilitates it because
it doesn't exist in a vacuum.
This is a browser that will get deployed
within a system that is actively
leveraging,
um,
things like social credit scores and the
social credit score, actually I will,
I will say scares me a lot.
Um,
the idea that we would be ranked based
on any number of different factors and
then have benefits sort of denied
to us based upon those factors.
So we wouldn't be able to
board a plane, um, that are,
that we would have sort of demerits
taken away from us because we used up too
many rolls of toilet paper. Um, the fact
that we would be sort of data flying,
everything does,
does this contribute to that effort
because that's a value that's implicated?
Does it, will it help exacerbate the
spread of facial recognition technology,
which is another thing that
I've worried about a lot. Um,
because in order to gain the benefits of
facial recognition technology of which
there are admittedly are many,
we can find the bad guy,
we can find missing children,
we can, um, uh, help those,
um, that, uh, uh, don't
have the ability to sense,
uh, in, in ways of others and a
bit in order to get a lot of the,
the real uses of facial
recognition technology,
not just the sort of minor conveniences
of unlocking your phone with your face
rather than your fingerprint, which
is fine, but I view as just a, uh,
a very incremental benefits. Um, but
in order to get the real benefits,
we will have to give up a
lot, almost everything, right?
We have to have cameras everywhere.
We have to have databases that are shared.
And I have facial recognition technology
depends upon the existence of a name,
face database that's they
can recognize people. Um,
and I think we have to think about
that, that value as well. And will this,
will this aid that in the
aggregate and is it worth then,
um,
uh,
defining the values of the company
based on that, right? Because,
because your values are reflected
not just in what you do but in,
but in what you build. Um,
and I think that it's, it's,
it merits a serious conversation about
the direction of a company and the ethos
of the company, um, with
the, with that creation. But,
but that being said, I, I'm,
I'd be scared to comment anymore because
I actually don't know the specifics of
the, of the project. So,
uh, so terms and conditions
seems like a necessary evil.
But clearly the way that it's done today
is pretty terrible because nobody reads
dumb. And now people are,
I guess, legally bound.
I'm not even sure if they're legally
blind in because nobody understands that
nobody reads them is can you
agree to something you don't read?
But besides the point, and there's no
expectation to meet them either. Right.
Which is another issue. But, uh, how
do you think that could be done better?
Craig, thank you very
much. I love that question.
So I just wrote an essay a little
while back called user agreements are
betraying you, uh, with the
idea that, that it, it's,
it's this abstraction, nuance tension
that's unreal. Unresolvable right.
We could either have a, someone proposed
as some point, a 100 word user agreement,
which says that's, that's, that's, that's
not even an advertising slogan almost.
Right? I mean it's, it's,
it's so sort of abstract.
This did not really tell you anything.
Um, I think that user agreements, um,
could be improved upon,
uh,
if they are written in a way that
they are written for basically the
transparency purposes because some
people do read them. Actually,
there's a really good article,
um, uh, by, uh, Mike [inaudible],
uh, called in defense of the long privacy
statements. And he says that people,
some people actually do read privacy
policies, regulators do, advocates do,
they serve in, Huh? Attorneys,
right? Attorneys do,
they serve an important hygienic function
for companies, right? So they let you,
they let you know, like internally like,
okay, here's where all our information is.
We've got stock of it.
Like it's a,
it's an incredibly good force functioning
tool. It's just not for users.
Right? And so my, um,
my preference would be to have a,
a regulatory regime.
And this is a little controversial
where there are certain things that you
cannot trade away in our user agreement.
So in other words,
there's a baseline set of protections
that cannot be compromised through terms
and conditions. We have this
in other areas of the law. Um,
and then that way users can agree to
them without worrying about them. Right?
Because I always sort of have this, this
like small sense of dread when I Click,
I agree. Like, I didn't read any of
this, but I don't know within, in there,
but I agreed to it anyway.
And they actually are
enforceable largely, right. So,
so the, the law, I teach
contracts sometimes too,
and the law of contracts
is that if you click,
I agreed in courts are
going to say you agreed. Um,
and I would like to have a talk about
things that are unwavered will so that it
basically, it didn't matter what was
in the terms of agreements, right?
Because they are important risk mitigation
tools for companies and they could
have nice, um, transparency and
accountability aspects to them.
We just have to stop pretending that
they're for users because the things that
shape user's expectations or the
design, it's the website. It's the,
it's the padlock icon. It's the button.
Thank you so much. I really appreciate it.
Everybody.